foreign
[Music]
that's Dave's grinder account oh yeah no
that's just the name Dave uses on
grinder he thinks it's funny uh but he's
not here where is Dave
um Dave is uh he's at the Smart uh
Financial theater or the Phoenix show no
no no no no no Houston Houston oh that's
right yeah Houston's because it's a
federal financial it's confusing
September 17th is the Smart Financial
Center in Houston he's doing a walk
through there doing like audio but do we
still have tickets yeah yeah we just
opened up some more yeah hold on a
second yeah hold on we do have yeah we
opened up some more tickets okay there
and buy them liveclutter.com at the
Smart Financial Center Houston September
17th is where Dave is so yeah Hannah
you see this I just right here we're
just and we were going to offer you some
comps not any tickets too that's
industry term for free tickets yeah no
no you wouldn't know that but you're not
getting any anyway this is what are you
are you what are you Dutch
either speech impediment are you
[ __ ]
what
oh
[Applause]
this fall prepare
for two
Rebels what a Cause
[Applause]
the rebels were the cause Comedy Tour
tickets on sale now at louder with
crowder.com tour